the Democrats have apparently discovered
the Fountain of Youth rage
speaking last week senator Bernie
Sanders a crazed elderly loon recently
spotted wandering around the country
shouting about wealth and equality while
closing on a second vacation home stated
quote you should be angry take your
anger out on the right people Mayor Eric
Garcetti of Los Angeles speaking to
Politico explained quote if we only turn
that anger inward I fear we become the
permanent party of opposition over the
next couple months we better get our act
together the Democrats are late to the
game during the 2016 election cycle
Republicans express their anger
routinely and richly Trump himself
cultivated that anger as he and Tuttle
rightly wrote a National Review in 2015
quote many conservatives are having
their Howard Beale moment they're mad as
hell and they don't want to sit down and
take it anymore
now anger is nothing new in politics
anger has dominated political discourse
since the days of Moses ask him how he
felt about a stiff-necked people
seemingly ready to throw him overboard
every few weeks and some anger is of
course justified if you're angry at
corruption in DC you have every right to
be if you're angry at a heedless
Leviathan grasping at your wages that
anger is justified even if you channel
that emotion in the wrong direction we
can only to understand the anger but
something new has happened to American
politics in the last few years
politicians have realized that the
simplest path to power is to humor
everyone's anger if you take someone to
anger away from them
you've emotionally castrated them more
important you run the risk of driving
them into the arms of someone who will
feed their anger an anger that will now
turn on you for the sin of having
discounted that anger in the first place
this is deeply unhealthy one of the
great lives of psychology dominant since
the era of Freud is that coddling
emotions it leads to more emotional
fulfillment actually coddling emotions
leads to emotional and healthiness it
even leads us to wah-wah-wah low in our
emotions anger feels good and it feels
even better when someone tells you
you're not wrong to be angry in the
first place if you crave emotional
payoff and if those around you are
taught to costate your emotions you're
likely to engage more and more often in
emotionally overwrought behavior bad
psychologists indulge their clients
emotional states good psychologists ask
whether those emotional states are
justified as social psychologist
Jonathan Haidt among other states
cognitive behavioral therapy a technique
used to treat those with emotional
disorders is generally as effective as
antidepressants for anxiety and
depression
therapy consists of identifying
illogical links in a chain of thought
that lead to an emotionally hazardous
place you might figure out for example
that you're attributing motives to
someone even though you have no evidence
about his motives or that you over
generalize or that you're looking only
at the bad things in your life rather
than at the good things once you've
identified your own faulty thinking you
can stop the emotional runaway train
politicians however are trained to do
the opposite politicians spend their
lives seeking the favor of others that
means they find it wildly beneficial to
nurse the emotions and the grievances of
constituents the customer is always
right of course it means that if a
constituent is angry the best option
isn't help break the chain of emotional
volatility it's to channel that
volatility into beating back enemies if
you wonder why generic congressional
support is so low but support for local
incumbents is so high this is why your
local congressman here is you and
understands you but the far away
government full of cronies and fools
simply doesn't on a national level such
pandering has become endemic it's why
Hillary Clinton presided over the
intersectional Olympics in 2016 in which
voters must constantly be reassured that
their anger at alleged victim hood isn't
illegitimate and why Trump spends
inordinate amount of time talking about
Rust Belt voters who must be reassured
that their anger at the system in China
and Mexico is worthwhile all of which
makes very toxic politics the founders
knew public passions were constantly at
risk of demagoguery it's why they
weren't Democrats they believed in a
system that would check passion with
passion and they believed in a system in
which each politician would be forced to
answer to so many different factions
he would be fully incapable of
satisfying all of them in Federalist 10
Madison eloquently laid out the problem
of demagoguery his answer gridlock
federalism various legislative entities
passions incapable of satisfaction at
the governmental level without such a
system Madison wrote the dust baptism of
the majority would rule quote if the
impulse and the opportunity be suffered
to coincide we well know that neither
moral nor religious motives can be
relied on as an adequate control Madison
was not wrong to rely on the intricate
framework of the American government as
a bulwark against the perverse passions
of the majority but he also relied on
local interests to supersede national
interest and diffusion of power to
defeat virtually all interests the
growth of the federal government has
rendered all such notions obsolete on
the one hand local interests can now
dictate national interests President
Trump can cater to the anger of a
factory worker by promising tariffs that
affect everyone on the other hand every
local politician can now campaign
nationally Eric Garcetti barely presides
over the potholes in LA but he's seen as
the national face for his party the
result a national pathology and the only
cure Americans must get real and that
means unfortunately
politicians have to be brave they must
tell voters when their anger is both
misplaced and unearned they must be
willing to stand with truth rather than
with the power of sympathy if they don't
the anger that politicians have
attempted to channel for their own ends
will eventually burst loose in ways
those politicians never anticipated I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay we're going to get to all of the
latest with regard to this horrific
shooting in Alexandria Virginia today
for those who don't know there was a
leftist apparent leftist psychopath who
went and shot a bunch of members of
Congress and their aides over at a
baseball field in Alexandria Virginia
they were practicing for a congressional
softball charity game is the only nice
thing in Washington DC and it has to be
ruined by a radical leftists who decided
to murder people and will talk about all
of that the fallout from that what it
means for free speech and who gets to be
blamed for all of this and I want to be
as clear on that as humanly possible but
before we get to any of that I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
blue apron so blue apron is V number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country everyone in LA is
using everyone all over the country is
using blue apron the way that works is
that you go on you register and then
they deliver to you the ingredients and
the recipes so you cook the meal at home
totally fresh if the ingredients aren't
fresh they make it right and the recipes
are just top-notch it's all five-star
cuisine like upcoming meals beef
teriyaki stir-fry with sugar snap peas
and lime rice three cheese and baby
broccoli Stromboli with tomato and
oregano dipping sauce but you make it
yourself so it allows you time to bond
with your family you don't have to go
out to a restaurant pay lots of money
for it instead you just go over to blue
apron and they deliver to 99 percent of
the continental US and 99 percent of
food to food deserts again the way that
this works is now you can spend under
$10 per person for a delicious meal so
you no longer have to spend tons and
tons of money in order to get a
fantastic meal plus again the family the
cooks together stays together check out
this week's menu get your first three
meals for free by the way the recipes
always rotate the first three meals for
free with free shipping by going to blue
apron comm slash Shapiro use that slash
Imperial you get those first three meals
free so you can try it out really an
amazing service again this blue apron
calm slash Imperial you'll love how good
it feels and it tastes to create these
incredible home-cooked meals with blue
apron blue apron calm slash Shapiro it
is indeed a better way to cook always
fresh always delicious okay so let's
jump right into the news so obviously
you know what I have to say about
political anger has some bearing on what
just happened in Alexandria Virginia so
here
is what we now know we know that the
shooter the alleged shooter is and I
always say alleged for legal reasons his
name is James T Hodgkinson he's
identified by The Washington Post
sixty-six years old and here's what the
Washington Post reports they say the
shooter at the GOP congressional
baseball practice this morning is James
T Hodgkinson of Belleville Illinois
according to law enforcement officials
Hodgkinson 66 owns a home inspection
business his home inspection license
expired in November 2016 and was not
renewed according to state records he
was charged in April 2006 with battery
and aiding damage to a motor vehicle so
he's got a history of some violence as
well here's some of the media coverage
of the Congressional baseball practice
shootings clip 19 so there were two bits
of gunfire and how long did a like pop
pop pop it was returned and another
bunch that it went off for a while I
would say at least four to five minutes
starting and stopping so it could have
been someone was trying to catch the guy
that was shooting at him or he was
beginning to take out everybody my
thinking was in the YMCA you said you
ran right into the house you felt
concerned kind of elaborate on what was
going through your mind I'm sure your
heart was racing you're in your yard
mowing the lawn and there's shots up the
street you don't want to get shot just
to move you're just horrifying they say
50 to 60 shots were fired
Congress Senator Rand Paul was there he
said if the police had not been there
there would have definitely been a score
apparently Capitol Police were there
because Steve Scalise who was shot he's
the House Majority Whip he he had
brought the some security with him and
the Capitol Police ended up shooting the
guy and apparently killing him this this
piece of crap James Hodgkinson
is indeed dead here's Rand Paul talking
about what it would have been stances as
they played out in Alexandria right now
we are hearing more details from mo
Brooks at Alabama Republican who was
among those present today at that
baseball practice he said this morning
in an interview of the shooter he was
going after elected officials it sure as
heck wasn't an accident and Rand Paul
the Kentucky Senator who was also there
said who have been warming up at a
batting cage during this practice he was
just keeping praise on the Capitol
Police who he says happened to be there
because the majority with Steve Scalise
was there he said had they not been
there it would have been a massacre this
morning Rand Paul and others
are praising the police specifically for
their bravery on this Mel Brooks as a
congressman on the scene he also
described the shooting and then there's
another GOP representative who said that
before the shooting this this guy
Hodgkinson walked up to him and asked
him if Democrats or Republicans were
playing on the field so yes there was
political motivation this would fall
under the category of political
terrorism here is representative
describing this this murderer comin or
attempted murder because I don't think
anyone has died yet except for the
shooter I asked asking whether it was
Republicans or Democrats practicing on
the field what I'd like to tosha's give
you an overview of what took place
we received a call of an active fear
shots fired
zero seven zero nine three nine minutes
after seven sporting my hair at the port
on Monroe the Simpson Park had that five
there was a practice game event for the
baseball team
we're representing some folks on the
hill we were there within three minutes
we do know that officers on the office
level police as well as three off ok
joke a terrific response by Capitol
Police they get there within three to
five minutes Governor Terry McAuliffe
was the governor of Virginia he of
course came out immediately with the
Democratic talking points whenever
there's a situation like this the
Democratic talking point is it must be
the guns now according to Rand Paul if
there's nobody there with a gun then
this guy just mows everybody down and he
can do it as leisure I mean he's
literally walking through a crowded area
there are kids there and they killing
people Governor Terry McAuliffe however
he says this is really just the result
of too many guns clip 24 you think
anything more need to do to protect
politician well let me say this I think
we need to do more to protect all of our
citizens I have long advocated this is
not what today is about but there are
too many guns on the street we lose 93
million Americans a day to gun violence
I mean I've long talked about this that
progress is early even on Denver said we
don't lose 93 million Americans a day
and again it was a good guy with the gun
who stopped the bad guy with a gun not
gun control laws there are background
checks this guy was from Illinois where
there's heavy gun control and we don't
know where he got the gun we don't know
if he went through a background checking
apparently as I say had a couple of
run-ins with the law he was charged with
battery and aiding damage to a motor
vehicle so he clearly had some issues he
probably shouldn't gotten a gun if there
was a background check so we will see
what is revealed but again the Democrats
always jump there instead of jumping to
a bad person decide to go off and here's
what we know about Hodgkinson Hodgkinson
hated Trump here's all something else
that we know about Hodgkinson Hodgkinson
love Bernie Sanders okay so we have all
sorts of graphics from his Facebook page
his Facebook page it's chief it's key
image is a picture of Bernie Sanders in
the Uncle Sam outfit he's got pages up
that he is that he's been tweeting that
he's been putting out on the Facebook
page talking about how corporations
write bills and Congress are as bribed
until it becomes a law here's something
that he just said quote I want to say
this was two days ago I want to say mr.
president for being an a-hole you are
truly the biggest a-hole we have ever
had in the Oval Office okay same day
make America great again resigned then
he put out on Facebook a graphic because
all in all it's just another bleep
the wall picture of Trump with his hand
against the western wall says the same
day Trump is guilty in should go to
prison for treason on June 11 please
read and pass on and there's a quote
from alternet stop fighting over who
created the world and fight against the
people who are destroying it in March he
put out on his Facebook page Trump is a
traitor from his destroy democracy it's
time to destroy Trump and company so
this is leading to the same conversation
that we always have in the country when
a domestic politically motivated
terrorist decides to go on a rampage and
we've seen this already in Portland the
guy who was responsible for murdering a
couple of people with a knife was a
Bernie Sanders supporter Democrats have
always tried to claim that Republicans
are responsible whenever there is a
violent crime they tried to claim the
jaren law fair whose legitimately an
insane person was responsible for
killing Gabby Giffords because of Sarah
Palin for some odd reason they trying to
claim the Oklahoma City bombing was
because of talk radio going all the way
back to the 1960s JFK and his
administration after his death tried to
claim that it was the toxic political
rhetoric and the climate against against
JFK that led to his assassination not a
communist stooge who shot JFK because he
was a communist again there is always
this conversation that happened and I
think that there are several points that
need to be made here one I am NOT going
to blame Bernie Sanders for the
attempted murder of these Congress
people I'm not he uses inflammatory
rhetoric Turner McCall from self uses
inflammatory rhetoric here is an example
yesterday there's McAuliffe going out
there about gun control clip one he was
talking about how there are treasonous
Americans presumably inside the Trump
administration coordinating with Russia
to steal the election he said there are
Americans who committed treason I think
as we get into this it seems to me that
Russia was actively involved in
destabilizing our democracy so where's
that American people somebody I believe
had to give him a road map somewhere in
this somebody was directing the Russians
on whose names to use what impact these
certain people sending a memo would have
on the American electorate I mean they
just didn't sit over in some cubicle
over there somewhere
in Moscow and figure this out okay so
there he is basically humoring the idea
that somebody has committed treason the
penalty for treason under the
Constitution of the United States is
death is that because Terry McAuliffe
actually want some nutcase to go and
shoot up a bunch of people No
I don't think so this is heated
political rhetoric it's pretty normal so
I want to point out a couple let's start
with this just because Bernie Sanders
says inflammatory things does not make
him responsible for what this guy did
any more than the fact that Donald Trump
says inflammatory things would make him
responsible if somebody had gone and
done this to Democrats okay that's not
how political rhetoric works in the
country I judge whether political
rhetoric is directly responsible for
violence if the political rhetoric
directly tells people to commit acts of
violence that's when political rhetoric
is responsible for violence otherwise
we're going to get into very dicey
territory where we decide to shut down
free speech because it could promote
violence that's the direction everybody
likes to move Barack Obama did a whole
campaign style rally after the Gabby
Giffords shooting in which he blamed
toxic political rhetoric from the right
and he blames lack of gun control and
then he suggested that basically the
right and his toxicity was responsible
in some way for all of this I'm not
going to do that I thought it was
immoral and Obama did and I think
tomorrow when anybody does it the way
that you can connect rhetoric and
ideology with actual violence is if that
rhetoric and ideology is actually
calling for violence so for example
radical Islamic jihadism actually calls
for violence governing Sharia law is a
call for actual violence against human
beings and one of the ways that you can
judge whether the rhetoric is actually
calling for violence is whether this is
a rare exception to a general rule or
whether it is a widespread belief a wide
held belief and a lot of people are
participating in it so terrorism is a
widespread thing it's happening all over
the world they're regimes that are
participating in it they're regimes that
are funding it and there are large
swaths of the population in the radical
Muslim world and a new just
fundamentalist Muslim world that are
supportive of the general beliefs of
some of the terrorists including the use
of violence okay that is not the case
here I'm not seeing the upsurge from the
left saying I'm so glad that this guy
went out and shot a bunch of a bunch of
Republican Congress people so I'm not
going to equate American left this with
jihadis and just because the left does
this to the right doesn't mean it's okay
for us to do it just because the
Southern Poverty Law Center tries to
connect every act by a loon who once
listen to Rush Limbaugh with Rush
Limbaugh's views does not mean that I'm
going to participate in the same thing
because I think it's disgusting when
they do it so it'd be equally disgusting
when we do it and I want to talk about
though I do want to talk about when
rhetoric is responsible for creating a
toxic climate and what that
chili means generally so I've talked
about when rhetoric is directly
responsible for violence well I'll try
and I'll talk about in a second when
it's sort of indirectly responsible for
creating a climate that creates more of
these sort of isolated events but before
I do that I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at tracker so if you lose
your wallet if you lose your phone if
you lose your keys and if it happens all
the time this is why you need tracker I
lose my wallet phone and keys all the
time or at least I did until we got the
tracker the tracker is a coin size
device you stick on your tees you stick
on your wallet you stick in your bags
you can implement the program on your
phone and then you can use the tracker
app to find everything in seconds and if
you lose your phone well then you press
the button on your tracker device or
even ask your Alexa and the phone will
start ringing even if it is on silent
tracker has the largest crowd locate
network in the world so it can find your
items even if they are miles away
tracker comm is awesome it's helped save
my marriage because we lose stuff all
the time right now if you go to traffic
or calm tra CK are calm and use that
promo code Ben you save 20% on any
tracker package you can save 20% on any
tracker package when you go to tracker
calm and use that promo event as you can
see the devices are exactly the size of
a quarter and they are they're not only
unproductive they are highly highly
useful so you never have to lose your
stuff again tracker calm and use that
promo code Ben's that they know that we
sent you okay so I've talked a little
bit about the the idea that left
rhetoric you know tournament calls
rhetoric Bernie tenors Rick I'm not
going to blame that rhetoric for this
guy going out and doing stuff and by the
way I'm not going to blame even Kathy
Griffin's rhetoric I'm not going to say
the Kathy Griffin is responsible for
this guy going out and shooting Congress
people because I don't think Kathy
Griffin told this guy to go out and
shoot Congress people or said I think
it's okay if you go out and shoot
Congress people I think she's an idiot I
think she's a fool if the Secret Service
actually thought that she was advocating
assassination they would have arrested
her and it is not a crime to say go to
things a lot of people today on the
right are going to do the Shakespeare in
the Park routine where Julius Caesar is
played by Trump and assassinated that
this is what led to the events of today
I'm not going to do that because I think
it's gross when the left does that yeah
I think that there can be a badly
interpreted play I think there can be a
play that I would think crosses some
lines without saying that it is directly
responsible for the violence now it is
true that as rhetoric and violent
rhetoric escalates on both sides
political I'll and it's been ignored on
the left by the media the right is
pointing it out with regard to Trump and
it is certainly true the Kathy Griffin
stop the Shakespeare in the Park stop a
toxic political climate is not going to
make rational people go out and shoot
Congress people but it is going to have
an outsized impact on what we in the
legal field call somebody with an
eggshell skull right the idea that
somebody is right on the bird and now
the climate has become so toxic the day
that he's going to go nuts and start
shooting people the toxic political
climate is indirectly responsible for
this so what does that suggest it
suggests everybody should rapture this
stuff down a little bit we keep hearing
the war rhetoric from the left we keep
hearing the treason the resist rhetoric
from the left they keep bringing the war
rhetoric from the right and the response
has been from from people on both sides
of the aisle to keep upping the ante
well if they use a tactic why can't we
use a tactic if they use violent
rhetoric why can't we use violent
rhetoric if they believe if the SPLC the
Southern Poverty Law Center blames the
right every time something bad happens
why can't we do that too
why can't we just keep making the
rhetoric why can't we just keep making
everything more and more and more toxic
okay listen I am NOT shy when it comes
to using rhetoric we've ever seen the
show before you've ever seen any of my
videos I'm not shy about speaking what I
believe to be the truth and I'm not even
try about using harsh language but when
it comes to advocacy of political
violence or giving the go-ahead to
anything that remotely hints at
political violence that's where we all
need to take a step back not because
it's going to lead to widespread battles
in the streets although we have seen
some of that with Antipa which actually
is a violent terrorist group not only
heavily but but it's going to have an
impact if the entire culture goes toxic
if the entire culture just becomes a war
of all against all then that doesn't
mean it's going to turn into open
warfare in the street but it does mean
that more nutty people who are right on
the brink are going to be pushed over
the line into doing something truly
awful and truly violent so here's my
recommendation everybody should take it
down a notch try to decide whether your
anger is justified before you vent your
anger try to decide whether something is
worth tweeting before you tweet it try
to decide whether that Facebook post
talking about how you wish Trump would
just die already is worth doing if
you're on the left and if you're on the
right
try not to respond by saying I hope you
die right let's let's all just take it
down a notch because I don't think that
either you're the guy you're posting
with is going to go and shoot somebody
but I think that somebody who's reading
might be outside it might be impacted in
outside fashion now I don't make
decisions and I don't think
anybody needs to make decisions about
their personal behavior based on the
nutcase who could go nuts but I also
think it's kind of immoral to talk in
these ways as a general rule so I think
that we should all take a step back in
that in that sort of in that sort of
notion and again I'm not saying we
shouldn't use harsh language I mean for
goodness sake I've signed books punch
back twice as hard using the Obama
rhetoric with regard to political
battles but that is not the same thing
as openly advocating for violence
against people on the other side of the
aisle obviously meaning things
figuratively is not a good thing and I
think that people including me should
maybe take a step back on all of this
and so instead of but in other words
instead of blaming Bernie Sanders
instead of blaming Donald Trump for
people who are bad doing bad things I
think we should recognize the supreme
country people should say what they want
to say but people should also take care
that maybe it's not a great thing if we
decide to inject the toxicity of
violence into our rhetoric at every
available turn and it's been just up
dramatically in recent years okay so I
no want to turn to more tacticity in our
political culture but you're going to
have to go over to daily wire.com right
now because we're going to discuss the
sessions here and what actually happened
yesterday in the session is hearing big
nothing burger we're going to talk about
why the Democrats were over their skis
on it but you have to go to daily
wired.com and subscribe right now if you
want that daily wired.com $8 a month
gets you a subscription to daily
wire.com even be part of the mailbag
which will be doing on Friday if you
have questions by the way for my pops my
dad is going to be stopping by and we're
going to talk about our brand-new book
and if you have questions for him about
me about anything else then send us
those questions we will do a mailbag
with my father on Friday so you can
subscribe for that or if you want an
annual subscription you get a free
signed copy of that book that I wrote
with my dad say it's so all about the
2005 White Sox baseball season and
fathers and sons in baseball it's a
really fun book great Father's Day gift
and I will sign it for you get it for
free and that's if you get an annual
subscription if you just want to listen
later go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
and make sure that you leave us a review
and subscribe we always appreciate it we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you